okay welcome everybody to their first
meeting of the first meeting the meeting
of the uh the council audit committee
and we're again we're back on YouTube so
I can just remind people to use the
microphones otherwise people won't hear
your words of wisdom
uh item one is attendances and apologies
I've had apologies from councilor Lloyd
I don't know
anybody else any apologies
no no thanks ask them two questions from
members of the public
none thank you item three Declarations
of Interest
obviously members are aware of how to do
that and four minutes of the 20th of
July meeting
can we agree those correct records those
who are there
thanks very much thank you
item five counter fraud and enforcement
team annual report that's Debian David
Wright I believe
okay thank you for inviting me for my
annual report
um as you've already seen the report
which was distributed last week
uh last year was a busy year uh but
nevertheless a very productive year for
both elements of the team which also
um self-included was also heavily
involved in the administration of the
various business support grants which
were brought in over that year
um
so in addition to the verification and
payment of the grants the appropriate
business one of the roles that the team
has continued to be involved in and will
continue to be for the foreseeable
future
um is in relation to the investigation
of a number of fraudulent applications
which were made to the authority during
those periods
um I want to discuss further in the
report but in addition to that work we
also spent a large amount of time
um being involved in a role in council
tax single person discount review which
we've worked with a third-party company
which has brought some productive
results uh that review was used to
Target householders who were claiming a
single person discount where data which
was largely credit based had highlighted
that there'd be additional persons
reside in the property
um
another part of that review was cases
where people had responded to the review
to confirm that they were indeed not no
longer eligible but had provided
incorrect information about when the
discount should be removed usually which
is quite quite common they tend to
indicate that the additional person or
persons have only recently moved in when
in fact to the evidence that we've had
indicates that perhaps that change may
have happened 12 18 months or two years
previously so we've been involved in the
investigation of that
um and that say that that's an ongoing
um piece of work that we're involved in
we've also in addition to the council
tax discount exercise and the grant work
we've also been working closely with the
our business rates team and this ties in
really with the the grants work as well
which had identified businesses who'd
been incorrectly claiming the small
business rates relief
um to reduce the business rates
liability by failing to this Square the
fact they had uh other premises either
within the borough uh or also externally
and there was a data matching exercise
which again we're still working on which
had identified businesses who'd
to either ourselves and or other local
authorities that only declared one
business had identified that they had
been receiving more than one business
support Grant into the same bank account
which investigation say this is an
ongoing process we've already had
occasions where businesses have been
found uh to be say in this Borough and
the neighboring boroughs which is work
that we wouldn't otherwise have picked
up on without this data matching
exercise
um
so I'll give you an example say if there
are a number of case studies which are
involved in included in the report which
um
I'll talk through a little bit more so
one uh such case was one that had
highlighted a company that had two small
business fund grants which had amounted
to twenty thousand pounds in respect to
two separate premises back in the
original uh Grant support which was
provided in the spring of 2020.
so they hadn't declared that they'd only
declared having one property uh our
records showed that two different names
had actually been used to register the
business one was in the name of the
business itself and one was in the name
of one of the directors of the company
that's how they'd registered for
business rates which is why it hadn't
been picked up normally uh but following
the data matching exercise which had
identified that the business support
Grant had been paid into the same bank
account an inspection that was
undertaken by members of our team showed
it was actually the same business
occupying both promises so there were no
in so whilst they were not eligible for
the small business rate relief they also
meant they were not eligible for the
grants either that they'd had the
business owner was interviewed here in
the town hall the accepted
responsibility for the relief um that he
wasn't eligible for the relief and as a
result we identified it he'd had 20 000
pounds in Grants that he wasn't eligible
for and also had to pay an additional 38
000 pounds in additional business rates
The Authority which previously he hadn't
been billed for
so that was one of the case studies
um
table two which is on page well it's on
page four of my report I think if you
can see there which shows the level of
income that has been generated or the
level of fraud or error that's been
generated by the team would you see
totally for 2122 amounted to 242 000
pounds just over half of that was in
relation to business support grants uh
as they expect probably similar figures
for this year if not higher
um and that's
um and so that's the fraud side but of
course there is another arm to our team
which is the litigation team which is
the one that's involved in the debt
recovery now as you can see from
the table on whoops page
six my report which is table three
just to touch on that
you see that over the last five years
the level of income or the level of debt
which the team has recovered has
steadily increased at the point that
last year 21-22 for the first time we've
actually recovered just over a million
pounds I would say when it comes to us
that's the end of the line so these are
debts that have initially the initial
process had failed to um work and it's
only when it's come to our team where
we're usually involving the threat of
litigation
um that these kind of monies are then
recovered
foreign
so just to go back to
um
case study two
which is on page five of my report
involves a case which as you can see was
quite a significant debt
um the team had been passed to debt
relating to a service user a lot of the
debt that we recover it does continue to
be relating to social care
social care debt so this was adapt where
the residential service users on paid
Residential Care charges uh have been
proved difficult to collect part of the
problem that we had a family member who
was acting as a power of Eternity a
power of attorney so we're supposed to
be acting in the interests of a family
member that they were representing but
actually hadn't made any payments
towards their mother's care charges and
as a result of this by the time the debt
had come to us over a hundred thousand
pounds was outstanding
we made contact with the daughter who
say was the power of attorney she
originally initially said that she would
arrange for the debt to be recovered but
then all lines of communication stopped
and made no attempt to either recover
the debt or contact us despite the fact
that she did have access to her mother's
finances
eventually
um through the solicitor
um that they then appointed a settle
amount was offered but unfortunately
this was only two-thirds of the debt
that which was outstanding so we did
decline that and it was only upon the
issue of a letter where we would advise
that we would not only take civil
enforcement action on the matter but we
would also be referring the matter to
the office of public Guardian who manage
Powers of Attorney it was only on that
threat that we did recover the money in
full and it was paid in two installments
similar problem again
um in case study three this is a
slightly unusual
um it wasn't so much that the service
user unfortunately passed away uh wasn't
um
obviously communicating with us or
anybody else was communicating it was
actually the firmer solicitor who was
supposed to be managing the estate that
we were having problems with
so this debtor had died unfortunately
and left a significant estate but didn't
actually have anybody acting for them
and whilst they it was a bit I don't
know if you ever watch a TV program
called hair Hunters where the trace
um members of the family or long-lost
members of the family who possibly
unaware that the family member even
existed or the month they were due this
money so it was through that they
actually did eventually or a similar
process they actually traced two distant
family members who were eligible to
receive quite significant proceeds of
the estate
um and again
unfortunately the solicitors perhaps
weren't as productive as they could have
been and it was only after contact was
made with one of the firm's senior
partners and we actually lodged a
complaint against this solicitor that
was dealing with it that we managed to
get any progress we did eventually they
appointed administrators to the estate
the executive the um the family members
did receive the money but of course
before that was
um handed out with our debt of 75 000
pounds was recovered in full so it kind
of highlights those two cases I feel is
it's not always just a case if somebody
can't pay it's a lot more complicated
than that unfortunately unfortunately
um we have the techniques and we have
the ability on the team because they've
become quite experienced in this to be
able to work through the cases do take
time but as you can see from these two
cases we get there in the end
um
so that's the debt and I say the
business support grants is
say this is an ongoing thing although
the administration of the grants has
gone hopefully there won't be any more
touch wood and I may have said the same
last year of course then Omicron arrived
um but as far as a no
support me on this that we won't be
doing this again
but that's not the end of the work and I
say the fraud team
um is now uncovering a large number of
cases where false applications been made
for a number of reasons
um either it failed to declare that
vacated the premises the businesses were
never there in the first place or as I
mentioned before the data matching
exercise where we've found in businesses
that are claiming grants across
different boroughs
um an example of that and I've already
sorry
um
of of this and they said this is where
having a consistent approach to invest
to managing the grants has worked having
the same people involved and I was
involved in these uh works because you
become the names the names of the
company start to register with you and
we had a case last year it was actually
during the uh the application of the
omicon grants which earlier this year or
after Christmas last year that it was an
investigation into that the Omicron
Grant application uncovered questions
about previous gun applications that had
been applied for and paid so this was a
company
um I won't mention the name but they
have a number of premises within the
borough
um some of which are open to the public
and we're retail premises which were
eligible for the grants that they did
receive but they'd actually claimed for
two premises that would actually use for
training in admin so therefore not open
to the public and therefore not ones
that would have been subject to the
ground
um we'd question this with them the
granted recipient was contacted and it
was finally confirmed what the correct
use of the premises were and as a result
of that we were able to recover uh just
over 54 000 pounds in overpaid grants
and I say that has now been repaid in
full
so that's what we did last year in terms
of how we've been working this year and
we're halfway through we will continue
to work within internal audit and within
exchecker Services we've a lot of the
work with Mark's team as well we work
together
um in nation to council tax non-domestic
rate social care all those kind of
things the data matching exercise the
national fraud initiative which will
again be um starting due to start again
we'll start releasing data for those
matches to be worked on so that will
keep us busy the business support grants
we've got the single person discount
review and also uh as I said touched on
before the other arm of the team which
is involved in the
um civil proceedings in relation to debt
so to the authority so been very busy as
you can see and I hope you can see will
continue to be productive
uh and that's that's my report so I
opened the floor if anybody has any
questions yeah thanks very much any
questions
thank you for your report could you put
a rough percentage on how many
fraudulent bits they're put in for the
covid business support grants can you
give a rough kind of
percentage and if I can ask another
question
um when do you expect that the
investigations of them to come to a full
stop
um well the entity first part
um well based on the figures it's
probably quite a small percentage I mean
none of those figures seem quite High
um I haven't got to hand the figures are
reported on last year so let's say for
argument's sake we end up uncovering
grants to the value of a million pounds
which sounds a lot
but if you think that we paid
the name is about 75 million
that's just the good because there was
two elements there was the grants that
we did which the local restriction
support grant that we restart ground to
there were another team in our strategic
growth who dealt with
um
different grants
so I can only really comment on those so
it's it sounds high but in in compared
to the the amount that we've actually
paid out it's probably not that higher
percentage it's probably less well it's
less than two percent uh with my limited
maths uh I would say that
um in terms of when will it end
um probably best because the next data
matching one of the data matching
exercise will touch on the latest
um the grants that we paid
so I would say probably hopefully in the
next 12 months providing there's no more
schemes introduced I would hope we've
probably broken the back of that then
and then we'll have a more accurate
figure
cancer Carter and then councilor wetton
thank you and thanks to you and your
team for all the um gulging work that
you're evidently doing a couple of
questions please um I think really
crudely it looks like you're reporting
the order of magnitude a million pounds
per annum is being saved slash recovered
how does that compare with the cost of
running the team question one give you a
second to think about that and question
two it sounds like some of the
activities uncovered and recovered are
fraudulent
is the council in a position to impose
fines for fraudulent activity in
addition to recovery money
um well take your second question in
terms of the grants is that what is that
what you mean
um that in terms of fraudulent activity
it could any any of what you covered if
somebody says I need a single person
discount and they're lying then right
that would equally be something that one
wouldn't approve of we get the money
back but is there an additional penalty
um
no no this is something that's been
raised previously that there are some
local authorities that have imposed
um
in effect fines they're not caught
administered fines I think there are
about 75 pounds for failure to disclose
council tax discount
um removals for example this was
something we explored when the team was
set up seven years ago but there wasn't
an appetite for us to do that I think
part of the issue was the cost of the
collection particularly if they're not
paid outweighs what you'd actually
recover in the extreme cases
um we would potentially look at
prosecution
of course then you're at the rest of the
court or whatever fines they imposed but
generally our approach accepting the
extreme cases in terms of the grant
cases we do have a couple of cases that
are currently going through
um potentially legal action
but we don't wouldn't normally impose
fines on them or anything like that it's
more evolved of getting the money back
that's the
that's the main agreement of the team
in terms of the cost of the team uh I
think when when the team was set up that
was basically our remake that we would
generate more income and it costs to run
um there's only six of us on the team at
present so I think we in terms of what
we uncover and in terms of what we
recover
um yeah with more than pay for ourselves
can I still win
thank you and um congratulations on on
all of this work it's very it's very
encouraging
um
fraud against the public purse is is
something I find is is awful and
especially in in the recent times we've
been in where um the government has set
out to help businesses and uh people
make fraudulent claims at uh at a time
when you know the nation was under
stress and the government's trying to
help and people take it unfair Advantage
so I'm really pleased that you've
managed to to close in on on some
hopefully all all of those uh people
um they said something caught my eye on
the um on the single person's uh
discount that you you mentioned um and
the data matching exercises
had given you some leads there
um
and and you made
um some positive moves there and I
noticed at the same time they
um featured in the budget monitoring
report there's a an increase in the
number of discounts being claimed so
you're finding more people who shouldn't
be claiming it and more people are
claiming it there's a bit of a conundrum
there and I'm wondering if
quite what's going on what's what's
causing the the increase in the
claimants and what's causing the
increase in the
um people inappropriately claiming is
there some message for us within all of
that
um
well I can't answer as to why the number
is increasing in claims
um I mean that that could be genuine
people are finding themselves there
could be a number of reasons why people
are now finding themselves living on
their own
um in terms of the number that we're
uncovering I think that's because as a
result of the work that we're doing
these kind of rolling reviews that's
what's uncovering them because these are
things that hadn't been previously
reported
and without because it's a targeted
review we're only sending these forms
out to people or the company that we're
working with are only sending these
forms out to people who has been
identified that they possibly shouldn't
be getting them
so I would say the reason we're getting
more is because we're doing this kind of
work
because there's a chance that otherwise
the the taxpayer wouldn't have reported
it either
as quickly as we picked it up or
possibly at all
and I say there could be a number of
reasons financial reasons why people
aren't disclosing this because if it
adds a quarter to your council tax bill
then that's quite a significant amount
um but I don't know why the number has
gone up
um I said there could be other reasons
for that
no I realized
my question may appear slightly unfair
to put it to you it's perhaps for some
for others to comment it was just the
the two bits of information coming
together
um just caught caught my eye and I yeah
I mean on the cases that we uncover we
we tend to find there's nothing to
suggest that well not not in all the
cases in the majority of cases there's
nothing to suggest that the discount
wasn't correct at the time it was
applied
so it's not as if you could say right
well perhaps we should be verifying any
applications before it's before we even
award the discount it's usually
Something's Happened and then it becomes
it's somebody who perhaps let's say for
example
um
a solo daughter that's been at
University
and quite you know quite rightly the
discount's been applied for when they've
gone but then they've not told us when
they've come back
so I don't know really what we can do
just because obviously when it was
applied for it was right so it doesn't
matter what checks we put in place it
would have been awarded but I think it's
it's the failure to report things I mean
we do remind them and I think with the
billing stuff there's a reminder and
I've done the website there's a reminder
or if people choose not to tell us until
actually prompted to
um I'm not sure what we can do I mean
they say because they're quite not
necessarily particularly high amounts so
I think going down the prosecution rate
in extreme except in extreme cases that
kind of deterrent isn't there
it's only when you publicize one if it
makes the national media as we have in
other areas of work that we've done that
that kind of thing is there but you know
it's just reminding people that this is
what they should be doing
people don't and
you're quite right with your with your
comments then and the it's the
cumulative figure isn't it that is the
the important one that
um justifies all of the work involved
okay
thank you chair and uh thank you for the
report and and again to add
congratulations to the hard work of the
team
um put in my um accounting head on I'm
sure you'd agree that that prevention is
always better than um recovery
um so it might not be for yourself it
might prefer for Graham but what are the
key lessons that have been passed on to
both the rest of the finance team as
well as the wider Trafford Council
um team in terms of um preventing some
of these problems
um happening not necessarily every
single one but just like the key the key
learnings from this year
um well I think the biggest thing where
you can you could argue that the
prevention was was the support business
support grants because there was so many
different schemes as each different
scheme was announced our verification
process got Tighter and stronger
and I think there was possibly more that
slipped through the net in the first one
back in March 2020
then by the end of it and I think it
because it there was a lot more not just
what the customer was
um asked to provide but also the
background checks things like companies
house checks stuff like that that we
were doing that was picking up because
these figures are only
ones that we were paid that which was
now recovered or identified for Recovery
there were also a lot that were rejected
in first place
so I would say that that's that's the
message is if if you put these things in
place well you can't necessarily do with
everything
um you know could say with this like
with the um the business rates the small
business rate relief we bought some
software two or three years ago now
which has picked up a lot where if
people just come to us and tick a box to
say this is my only business there are
background checks made
um which we'll pick up across the
borough whether any such businesses
trading elsewhere
so that that's that's another thing that
we've brought in so again these won't
figure in these figures because we've
stopped the relief being awarded in the
first place
thank you Council
thank you thank you
thank you for the very comprehensive and
uh in-depth details we have given
a good question and a very simple uh
when we recover the amount from the
people those who claim fraudingly
and then it the the same amount comes
back to the same pot
where we have given to the to the
customer who fraudulently claimed
yeah
um for example council tax discounts yes
any identified go back into the council
tax okay which is obviously from forms
so it will be voted us onto the same
part for example council tax or a
business sport so it will go back to the
same part yeah I mean the business the
business support Grant unfortunately
it's not our fault okay we administered
that on behalf of government agencies
yeah that's fine so we don't get the
funds for that so it will go back to the
government then we yeah the money has to
go back to them so it is clear enough
thank you
okay any more questions anybody
you know a couple more thanks David for
that very interesting report I think
no right away uh very interesting report
I think hopefully apart from the money
you do recover you're a deterrent to
people anyway people know your in your
group are there you're a deterrent to
people who might be thinking of uh
not being entirely honest in their
claims or you're probably saving us a
lot more than the million pounds that
you uh you've actually seen in cash
so thanks very much
cheers bye
can we now go on to item six external
audit progress report
which I think is uh
it's current of course thank you chair
um I'll be fairly brief actually because
um we're at that stage in the audit
cycle if you like where there isn't much
happening uh from my perspective so we
have received uh your accounts we got
them uh at the end of July which was
what we'd agreed with your Finance team
but we agreed that in order that there
was
um you know time for people to do the
right the right work at the right time
we would conduct off our final accounts
visit and our work if you like through
um October and November so although
we've been doing some work uh off-site
to move things along we're not actually
starting the audit in Earnest if you
like for another a couple of weeks
um and we intend to report back to you
in November the one sort of challenging
that timetable if you like is that there
is a national technical issue in respect
of infrastructure asset accounting
um which may prevent us from signing off
your audit opinion as it is doing for
all other local authorities that have an
asset an infrastructure asset in their
uh counts and this second section of the
report the part two section if you like
is just a list of national Publications
that you may be interested to read
um they are to help you fulfill your
governance responsibilities now don't
bring them here because I'm particularly
concerned about anything that the
council is doing
um more that there may just be helpful
to you
um the only one of those that I really
would draw attention to
um is the second one on the list which
is uh departments uh recent updated
guidance on the flexible use of capital
receipts
um you'd be aware that there is an
option for you to use some Capital
receipts flexibly so when you dispose
for Capital asset the receipt is
generally only available to spend on
Capital items there is an opportunity to
use that for some things that might
normally be more more properly
considered Revenue in certain
circumstances whether that's about
transformation and helping you to
um take out permanent costs if if you
will going forwards so it's just a very
a very minor change really there and
also a requirement for you to submit
your plan if you like to to use any
receipts like that to um governments
ahead of time and the reason I bring it
to your attention is that the tighter
the position gets financially for the
council in Trafford here as well as all
those
um the more likely it is that you might
want to consider your options to use
Capital receipts so I'll stop talking
there but I am very happy to take any
questions
thanks any questions
[Music]
councilor Thompson person councilor when
example of
projects we could use
pixel receipts on so that we can get my
head around that
if I can respond on that I think
we've got the full awareness of the
flexible user receipts I think in the
last
few years whilst it's been in we've not
applied it purely because of the demand
for supporting our capital investment
requirements on our fixed assets
um that's not to say in 20 in 20 when we
set this year's budget we opted to use
it to a relatively small degree to help
fund our transformation team and it it's
really expenditure that gives you
longer term benefits so the
modernization transformation teams
involved in in looking at those
transformative projects so that that's
an allowable expense and we'll be
looking at doing similar things when
we're setting the 23 for Budget as well
but totally mindful that the capital
resources we've got is a finite part and
we've got to try to fund the investment
the needed investment in our fixed
assets as well so it's a prioritization
thing that we consider as well
[Music]
Coastal wetton
mine was the same question actually I
was just interested in hearing what
scope there is
um available so it perhaps is something
we'll uh we'll learn more about going
forward anyway
I can look forward to the budget and no
doubt I'll hear something about it then
okay any further questions for anybody
no thanks Karen thank you for that
can we move on to item seven budget
monitoring report Grandma are you doing
that
yeah certainly I'll take this report
um yeah so this is our budget monitor as
at period four so it's it's the position
third the way through
um the financial year and it's our
projected expenditure up to the end of
the year uh compared to budget
doesn't make good reading
um
but we're not alone local governments
being battered
um
across the country
in respect to demand pressures and also
the bigger item is is the inflationary
impacts so I'll just I'll tell you just
quickly through some of the headlines in
this report so the projected overspend
for us up here for 6.91 million
um
slight Improvement on where we were
projecting at period two
and and the real key movement around
that
is the way the benefit we get from
interest rate changes
so interest rate changes you've heard us
come with the treasury management report
so this committee saw the way we manage
and invest Surplus cash balances
um
we benefit when interest rates go up so
that's that's the reason that that
positions benefited a little bit at
period four but
it's still a difficult position to be in
just breaking that figure down of 6.91
million
um
when we look at the council's
controllable net budget about 192
million which I think is in table one
192.5 million they overspend against
that in terms of what I will control say
that is the controllable overspend it's
about 900 000 pound so
just looking into that detail
and to break that down we're seeing
pressures
on our children's services particularly
the home to school transport provision
slight pressure on children's placements
as well so Children's Services is is and
continues to be a concerning area
um
but relatively speaking when when you
look at what other districts are
encountering around the numbers of
children in need they've got looked
after children
it's not not that of a difficult
position compared to what some other
authorities have got but still an issue
for us
um the place directorate is where we
budget for the returns from our asset
investment strategy
so
we're seeing the difficulty in
maintaining levels of income that we
have done in previous years and I think
I've said that at previous committees
and that continues to be the case so
there are service pressures within the
budget position
come against that what we can see
halfway down table one is Council wide
budgets so these are some of our Central
budgets this is where we hold our
contingencies our treasury management
budgets
and we've taken a view at this stage
that we can release some contingencies
that were put into the budget for 2223
um
the rationale for doing that is that the
contingencies were put in there were
temporary contingencies put in
to cover the recurring impacts of corvid
um so would our car park income which
was depressed during corvid how would
that return I would plan an income
return
we were budgeting with these temporary
contingencies that would continue to
have some problems in 2223 not as severe
as expected so that's quite a good news
in the ability to release that
contingency the other actor within the
2.6 million there is what I've called is
what I've talked about around the
treasury management investment income
returns so
across our controllable budget is just
over 900 000 pounds of an overspend but
what's what's obviously the big ticket
item within the the budget monitoring
position is the impact of inflation
so two real items there first one I'll
talk about briefly is pay so that
National pay negotiations
um
the employers have made a pay offer of a
flat rate of 1925 pounds per member of
staff
at the moment I think Unison is the only
Union to agree or its members to agree
to that
um I think we wait for the results of
unite and GMB to come back before we
will know whether or not that figure is
ratified if it is what does that mean
for the budget
broadly equivalent to about six percent
on average pay rise
um we're budgeted for a two percent pay
rise at the start of the year at every
one percent accounts of eight hundred
thousand pound so
that's over three million pound to start
with and the other volatile area within
that projection at the moment is energy
um still a real concern
um and we're budgeting for quite a
significant energy increase and we
continue to work with our energy
providers
um we work with the Yorkshire purchasing
organization who who negotiate our
energy for us and other authorities
um
and to secure best rates they have done
some Advanced buying but we're still
exposed to risk this year but obviously
we know in the mini budget announcement
last week we had the the energy
um relief scheme so we need to see how
that plays out as well so there's an
element of protection put in that so
I think we think at the moment best
estimates we've got Within These numbers
I think we've got a fair degree of
confidence around the pay number a
little bit of less confidence around
energy
um and that's what's contributing to the
overall position I think what we're
doing about that
um we still have contingencies within
our budgeted position so
if if things go to plan depending where
demand for services goes we might be
able to release some of those
contingencies back at year end and that
will mitigate that pressure
um
I think what we're also trying to do is
management action around things like
reducing energy consumption saving
energy where we can and our company
campaign's gone out recently across the
council
um we're also looking at one of the
biggest items of expenditure for the
council is p
so we are looking at our vacancy
protocols on non-frontline services to
see if that can save save on Staffing
budgets as well
um as you'll know from
discussions that we've been having we've
got a finance and change board which is
looking closely at the 23-4 budget and I
think what we're really mindful of of is
in identifying proposals for 23.4 are
there any of those that we could
accelerate in 22 23 to mitigate this
position
um
we weren't blind to the fact that we'd
have budget pressures when we started
the financial year so we have also set
aside a small element of earmarked
reserves and we reported that at outturn
so we've got about three million of
specific earmark reserves to cover the
inflation risks that we knew would be
coming our way
um for 22.3
I think just some other aspects of the
report very briefly around collection
funds or what we're collecting council
tax and business rates
relatively stable at the moment small
benefits on council tax collection
the savings and income program that's
built into our budget for 22.3 was about
5.3 million pound
we are showing a shortfall against that
Target but that is predominantly from
the income streams from the asset
strategy so we're about 1.3 1.4 million
pound adrift of that at the moment
um and then the capital program there's
a section on the capital program that
where we've reset the budget
to give us what we hope is a deliverable
level of budget that we can can actually
deliver this year we have also included
in that section some of the impacts that
we're seeing around inflation inflation
on material cost inflation on contract
prices uh leading times for materials as
well which which does affect performance
as well so
I think
a really difficult position and I don't
think in the short term it's going to
get much better for us and obviously
what we're doing at the moment there'll
be a report goes to Executive on the
24th of October which will be an
interesting one setting out
progress towards delivering a balanced
budget for 23 24 so I think there's some
quite crucial reports coming up with the
authority
happy to take any questions yeah thanks
thanks very comprehensive councilor
Winton
I think I may well have said before that
I think this is a as a regular report
it's a fascinating report and there's
always some
key messages in there for us
um I'm wondering
with some of the messages that are
coming out of this one given the fast
moving Financial picture that
um we're experiencing the moment it's
it's hard to keep up with everything
I've listened to an hour of News Radio
tonight which
uh was all financial and none of it good
good news and as one new Financial story
arrives others have forgotten but they
don't go away so it's it's all piling up
so with that in mind
um I'm just wondering about how
confident you feel about the collection
rates for uh council tax and business
rates
um
do you do you think you will achieve
your original forecast so you're gonna
are you gonna have to visit them again
because
uh you know resident residents are under
pressure with financial pressure
businesses are under Financial pressure
you did share some um collection rates
movements to have with me quite recently
but but I just feel sure they they must
be dynamic again now and I'm wondering
how much of a concern that is for you
it's a real concern I think
we presented
um last week
around how we the processes around
collection for council tax to another
group of councils um
I think for Trafford we we when we set
our budget in February and I suppose
once this year matures and we get that
data for this year that'll really then
feed into the February budget position
so we'll
will assess how we're doing we assume at
the moment that our what we call our
ultimate collection rate what do we
think of of this year's council tax debt
that we've raised how much we will We
collect that's not necessarily year in
year last year as an example I think
we're about 97.5 in year collection
the ultimate collection is what do we
then collect in year two and year three
because obviously not everybody pays you
would not get everything in year one so
ultimate question but it's 99 percent
um she said well there's not much room
for maneuver there is the
um
going through corvid we were bracing
ourselves what would happen there so we
did reduce down the overall collection
rate at that point
I think we were pleasantly surprised
what
how how buoyant the tax revenues were
even despite covered in Trafford so they
were quite buoyant
but we've now reverted back up to this
99 position that's where we are in 22-3
but we will revisit well I think we'll
have to the cost of living crisis is
something we've we've got to be mindful
of when we're setting the budget and I
think
you probably see references to little
reserves being created at points in time
and I think that's us trying to
trying to brace ourselves in case these
things happen
um but I think as this year matures and
that information comes to light we'll
have to take that assessment and that
ultimate collection rate before the
February budget report
um and then in fact we'll be working on
that
broadly I think from period six onwards
tell it and what does that say so I
ideally will know before Christmas and
we'll sign off a tax base
that references what we think that
figure is that's signed off in about
January
um yeah it's worth bearing in mind I
mean this death lasts for 10 years we're
still collecting debt now from 10 years
ago so if the I suppose the rate that
we're collecting that cash can vary over
the next year two years but ultimately
it will still be pursued
for the next five six seven eight to ten
years so even though we've got a bit of
a glitch here and we will we will expect
to see some reduction in that because
when cash flow it's one of those debts
probably that will be prioritized
against pain energy bills or even basic
things like food
um ultimately when hopefully things
start to recover that debt will start to
then trickle back into the council so
it's never written not it's never not
collected until the day we write it off
as I say we're still collecting debts
from 10 years ago
yeah I I understand what you're saying
there and that's it's an important
element within it what I'm
um worrying about are some of those
debtors who actually go under
um
obviously that's mainly likely to be
businesses and there's so many
doomsday stories that are being banded
around to cheer us all up
um that it does just make you wonder and
at the moment I think
certainly in my own household we're
holding our breath we're having a clue
what our next power bill is coming it's
going to be like uh and I think a lot of
people are in that situation until that
that bill actually comes through the
door we understand
the actual costs and the help that we
get and how it all Nets out
um
I think there's a lot of households that
are just waiting to see what
what that um actually what their final
impact is so just for such volatile
times and you can't believe really that
you know even more stories come out as
you you know day day by day even more
pressure is emerging
thank you
okay councilor Thompson then councilor
Carter then consider anything
used to be next year when he never
really will have to put up the council
tax
um to protect our services
and people residents will be suffering
properly the cost of living crisis so I
think we'll start to measure how much
council tax collection uh will be
impacted in the next few years
that's not a question
thank you I didn't know you've made
statements
um a couple of questions I'll do them
one at a time just to um avoid
complications in your appendix 3 you
talk about a digital strategy and
investment of a hundred thousand pounds
but there are savings yet to be
identified
does that mean that we spent 100 Grand
in order to get some savings and we
haven't gotten them
and if so is there any explanation for
that
to page 59.
yeah I think
what we've part of the financing change
board and one of the one of the key
themes for us is digital
and where can we what efficiencies can
we get across our across all our
services from digital and I think
I think with anything you probably
you're too ambitious sometimes in terms
of time skills for delivery
so just to explain what I mean there
we've
we did anticipate savings from a digital
strategy and still do across the life of
our mtfp next three years
what we had to do to begin with though
was was identify opportunities develop
develop a software platform
get a partner to help us then go out to
the services and div and try to identify
a program we're at the stage where we've
identified a program and we're looking
at how we can develop that but
inevitably the reason that that figures
are an unachieved saving is that that
program slightly delayed from where we'd
anticipated
um but it but it is continuing it and it
still remains in a key strand on the
investor finance and change program so
is it correct to say that whilst it's
delayed we're still anticipating making
that saving at some point absolutely
thank you
um
I don't know if you brought your crystal
ball
um what would you assess is the
probability of additional Government
funding coming for 20 to the next
financial year to cover some of the
costs of the economic crises we are
facing
I think
Slim
I'll not put a number on that but I
think it's slim I think what we heard
last week was that
the the spending what I would call the
spending review control totals so what
what does a government
plan on putting into public expenditure
I don't think they are looking at
changing those numbers so they work into
the spending review totals that they had
last time so there won't be additional
funding but I think what we've heard is
that with the mini budget last week
that said
there was the tax reversal on the
national National
the health sorry the Health and Social
care Levy
that reversal meant that was generating
13 billion pound of income of funding to
support the Health Service and social
care
the majority of that funding was going
to the health sector to cover the
backlogs that they were facing some was
coming to local government and adult
social care and I think
from what Liz trust has said is that
there'll be a rebalancing of that and I
suppose one example of that was that at
the back end of last week there was an
announcement of 500 million
to be moved across from the Health
Service to social care to support a
hospital discharge fund
so we await the details so you think
there's probably going to be more
support like that than General support
towards the council's general
inflationary and other costs of living
pressures that's just my view at the
moment
that's cancerous
thank you um I know the council's in the
process of developing its own uh warm
bank or Library plus type schemes that
we've seen across great Manchester uh
are there any initial costings for uh
for the scheme in Trafford and are there
any anticipated hurdles in terms of
budget in delivering that this winter
probably a specific question that we'll
take away I've not heard of any budget
issues at all and I know they've been
looking at that funding and the funding
streams around that
um
can I take that away and get back to you
thanks very much any further questions
anybody
well thanks a lot uh if you would send
that reply could you send it to all of
us please yes thank you yeah
thanks Graham for that uh
very worrying uh summary of the
financial future uh
no you're we're just shooting the
messenger really aren't we really we're
not not your personal responsibility can
we go on then to item eight Insurance
performance report is that you Dave yeah
all right thank you chair
um for those new members and um you this
is an insurance update Report with an
annual report that we're bringing in
every year
um I can't actually believe it's 12
months ago since last time I presented
it last October but um but basically the
the the reports in three parts covers
the cost of insurance claim patterns and
and numbers of claims and then there's a
bit forward-looking in terms of uh what
potentially is coming down the line for
us
um so just in terms of the uh the way
the insurance budgets uh structured
um we're self-insured to a large degree
to try and keep the costs and premiums
down uh so our next one on page 74 of
your pack shows the the type of
insurance policies that were covered
from employee liability public liability
motor and then personal injury the likes
of that and and then some of the
accesses for each one of those generally
in the range of 250 275 five thousand
pound I was self-insured up to that
limit and then there's an aggregate stop
loss so we don't if we have more than
some more than two or three claims in
there the there's a there's a stop loss
of a maximum amount for instance 750 000
pound after that the insurance
um provider will kick in to pay out
above that figure
um so it's in terms of the um
um the actual
um the budget is set aside we have a
revenue budget which covers the cost of
insurance premiums
um any any claim costs within the level
of access that we have to pay up to 250
000 and we also set aside a provision on
the balance sheet which covers the
amounts for historic claims yet to be
paid
um they're assessed by an independent
actuary that comes up and says right
this is the amount we recommend from
your claims history that you set aside
and those claims yet to be incurred in
the likes of that so we set that aside
on the balance sheet from that Revenue
provision and we pay the claims from
there and then we also hold Insurance
Reserve which is again it's a balance
sheet item which basically covers
um any risk items in terms of drawing
off any excesses So within the within
the insurance Reserve we have about one
and a half million pound that's set
aside to cover about three large
insurance claims 250 000 pounds and a
balance of risk from uh Municipal Mutual
Insurance which was a legacy insurance
company set up by by local government
that was wound up about 10 years ago so
any any Legacy claims in there included
from that insurance Reserve
and and then we've recently increased
its firm advice from the actuary
potentially emerging claims that haven't
yet transpired on yet hit the system so
they've recommended just to keep some
money back for that
so in terms of the revenue budget it was
quite a good year we've seen a reduction
in the number of actual payments and
uh so the amount that we need to set
aside for for the provision Savings in
the premiums as well
um so we at the end of the uh with a
gross under spend of about 89 000 pound
they actually came along as and
highlighted some of these potential
emerging claims recommended that we
start to build up some Reserve towards
those so we've set that 89 000 pounds
we've increased our reserve for that one
so overall it's a neutral outturn
and in terms of the actual uh number of
claims that's covered in section three
and generally it's good news we've seen
a reduction
um in the claims
um from 290 000 uh sorry 390 claims 1920
reducing to 209 2021. it's generally a
reduction in in all areas
um possibly the lights in 2021 was a
tail end of the lockdown and covered the
highway traffic and the lights and that
was probably not uh was lower so the
number of claims coming through from
from Highway injury and Highway
properties
um has been lower than average for
instance Highway injury 42 claims in
21-2 against an average of 73. the same
with Highway properties
um Highway trees
um 49 sorry 47 claims it gives an
average of 49.
generally it's it's a bit it's a it's an
increasing Trend in that area uh climate
change obviously dry Summers drying out
the the ground uh is meaning root damage
and things like that talking to take
shape and we've been working with the
tree unit we've done we did a tree
assessment uh where they focused on
trying to focus on uh risk policy and
management for that one the introduction
of software to try and manage those
claims and public liability these are
generally no numbers potentially high
costs if they do uh come to be paid out
the the include cases of data breach and
obviously with the gdpr regulations if
there is a data breach
um it can it can affect a large number
of claims generally speaking it's human
era where emails have been sent out
information hasn't been redacted
um and then safeguarding claims uh
within within that category
um so there's been a court case where um
there's more
um potential claims coming from there
from failure of care and it's called
vicarious liability where
as an employer were liable for the
wrongdoor of employees even though it's
not our fault so for instance a foster
carer case going back 20 years ago there
might be a case of abuse on that one
these claims are now coming on as a
vicarious liability responsible for the
employer which would be I was indirectly
and this recent court case has as
highlighted that so there's potentially
more claims coming through from there
um
so in in terms of I thought the good
news we've got a high defense rate uh 74
uh defense rate obviously that then
feeds through into potentially lower
premiums and lower playing costs and the
lacks of that
um in terms of section four looking at
the things that are coming up through
the market
um obviously inflation is is in fact
it's affecting the payouts potentially
on that one labor shortages
um and all of that side of things we're
looking at doing this piece of work
obviously with grenfell insurance and
looking at their liability particularly
around clubbing so we're doing some
detailed work in terms of looking at uh
surveying all the properties over a
certain value of five million pounds in
what type of insurance cladding what's
manufactured from our distance that the
buildings are from other buildings in
the perimeter so we're doing some work
on that side of things and so data
protection claims they're always they're
all there are always a risk and some
good news the court settlements have
knocked Backs from the opportunities and
low value claims uh recently so that
that's good news on that one we work
obviously with it within the
organization looking at the information
governance training staff awareness and
trying to to stop the beaches happening
in the first place
and cyber cover
um this was a topic that we would try to
look at getting cyber covers so when
we've had like a data data breach
um we've had um backing into the system
that potentially all these risks are
growing
um trying to get covered is quite
elusive at the moment the the market is
is the insurance Market is quite uh
cautious of offering cover on that side
of things and we have been engaging with
the Brokers and I.T colleagues in order
to
um to try and formulate a a policy
structure that we can actually get a
decent quote from it so we've been
working with them it's we've identified
good practice where we need to tighten
up and some of the some of the areas and
investment to try and solve the problem
obviously before it happens
and and then the insurance renewal
that's due up uh every three years so
that's that's due in 2023 obviously the
impact of inflation uh is something that
we're aware of we've built some
provision into the medium-term plans to
to address that but I think the fact
that we've got a good team at working
collaborative collaboratively across the
council demonstrates that we've reduced
our risk we've seen that with a
reduction in premiums and reduction in
claims so hopefully that will Cascade
into lower premiums going forward
so that's uh that's my summary of it if
you've got any questions oh good okay
any questions
and Council Morgan
thank you um
it's been a while since I've seen a
report on on insurance
well for my problems than yours but
um I I found it fascinating how it works
for the council this this self-insured
uh aspect and clearly it it's a it's a
good story
um and it's it's very interesting seeing
just the the defense
rates that are shown on in one of the
charts that the very high success that
you have there
um I just had a couple of uh things to
um just ask a question on uh there's a
mention in in terms of employers
liability and this
um
hybrid way of working
and it caught my eye that um
a personal injury claim was received
from something which is three years
post-incident
and with the big move towards working uh
at home
um
is there a concern there about a
vulnerability
down the line
um from from the big change of the
volume of people working at home
and
um
a bit of a sort of a
what-if
um question about the highway property
damage and you mentioned it's
particularly vehicles and potholes
um
do you there's no mention of
um costs there there's there's your high
success rate in in terms of the the
claims Etc
but do you ever look at the
um amount that is paid out compared to
the amount that is spent on repairing
potholes and trying
work out maybe it will be better if we
filled more potholes in or even dare I
say the converse of of that is is there
a correlation that that may indicate a a
benefit or disbenefit to the council
with a different approach on that so if
that's a bit uh convoluted question but
I hope you got the gist it knows yeah I
suppose for just the first point in
terms of the uh working from home and I
think that's something that the council
have recognized the potential for it and
you know there is um
in terms of a structured approach to
actually addressing that risk and
um the the council or are offering a
full uh assessment of
um the home environment and also
released an employee scheme for any uh
equipment chairs desks
um and then the full workstation
assessment so the whole environment is
as if you're working in the office in
terms of making sure you're the health
and safety there that the height of the
screen and all that side of things so
that's what the council is offering and
this week it
um it was this week last week that was
publicized for anybody who uh the this
health the assessments are done with
malingerial input to make sure they're
all recorded and registered and if
there's any equipment required from that
it says purchase from this from the
scheme has released a couple of last
week so on any same desks and chairs and
the lights that are available for that
side of things and I suppose then the
secondary point to that is making sure
that the staff are trained in
appropriate practices then you know they
would be in an office making sure that
they're taking regular breaks and all
those type of things so I suppose as an
employer we're discharging that from
from those aspects um You probably still
will have employees working as a casual
environment starting a city with a
laptop on the on the on the knee but I
suppose again it's an education point
that um there's potential long-term
issues with back problems if they don't
apply to the policies and that's in
terms of the the highway
um
damage
um It's relatively this this is one of
these things risk versus spend and I
think you know as any organization
um it's it's a question of the the
payout for property damage to cars and
tires and things like that relative
relative terms is relatively minor
um so the highway it's function do look
at that risk analysis and say is it
worth
spending
um you know x million pounds to fill all
the potholes in versus the risk of
paying out but that the bottom line is
damage to uh cars and um and to uh to to
Vehicles like that is relatively
small payouts so no one so it is a test
yeah
okay
Council Morgan
uh thank you chair it's a really quick
explanation point which I'm sure when
you say I'm going to field after page 75
Annex two and what does res stand for
before
oh it's a reserve that's the amount that
we the provision yeah they say so you
you should set aside that so the claim
comes in to look at it so set aside
thousand pound Reserve so that's the
amount we say we're in fencing the claim
comes in it gets assessed damage does
that we might only pay out 20 pound
fifty pound hundred pound you know
really that Reserve is then re-released
back into the pot for that so we look at
the total Reserve of all the claims
which they actually actually comes up
and then broken all of them to say right
you need to set up this Reserve that's
the ultimate thing we keep an eye on do
you assess those you know like because
obviously you won't release them
straight away do you assess them in
terms of likelihood
yeah yeah yeah
I mean I know there'll be a Prudence
element but you'll be reapplying a
likelihood that's right so they come in
and then they say there's your reserve
you provision ephemer amount is is
relative to that what's the likelihood
of payment that generally the cautious
when they set the reserve up and they
just come in and
trust anything under that so on a lot of
occasions yeah perfect thank you
thank you hey anybody else
no well thanks for that uh Dave item
nine audition Assurance report for April
to June 2022 oh mark
thank you chair
um so this is the the first update for
the committee this year in terms of uh
progress against our 22-23 internal
audit plan which was approved back here
in March
um
There's a summary in terms of section
three
um they're on page eight he just briefly
talks about the main areas of focus
during those three months
um which included a number of audits
around Financial systems and and
services
um a bit of a focus on schools as well
with the backlog we had from last year
um the impacts of the pandemic and
there's also been some work we've been
required to do in terms of signing off
certain grants
um to sum up during the the time looking
at section four there in terms of the
opinion levels we've given
um there were six final reports issued
where we gave opinions
um and we have just a reminder of four
opinion levels uh the top one being
substantial
um two of the six uh sorry four of the
six were substantial opinions uh and the
second highest level reasonable
um two two were given that there are a
number of other reports at draft stage
and I'll I'll pick up on those with you
the next update in November
um for those uh reviews that we have
issued final reports in each case
um where there are there are any
recommendations
um there is there an agreed action plan
that we can we can follow up against
them
um
you'll see there on page 81 that starts
a listing there of the different reports
uh we issued in the period and things
like licensing
um Trafford assist you see there's four
different schools there uh and then some
draft reports around adult social care
home to school transport and another
school
um and also two grants public sector
decarbonisation scheme and also contain
management outbreak from the covid fund
um in terms of all the work we did I did
probably it's probably largely picked up
in the last meeting in July so there's
reference there to the input we've had
around the Strategic risk register the
annual governance statement and and also
other references within our annual uh
head of internal audit report work
around national fraud initiative
um
terms of impact of our work during April
to June in terms of uh management
responses
um pleasing to see all the
recommendations we've made during that
period were agreed by management
um in terms of work we do looking at
implementation of recommendations or
give the committee more of an update on
that in the next update for the end of
September there was one follow-up work
audit completed in April to June but
I'll provide an analysis of a number of
follow-ups we did at the next meeting in
November
um just in terms of progress against the
plan
um see Section 8 of the report there we
we in terms of resources we we we put
around the the time of the number of
days that we'd expected to in the plan
and we had a Target uh number of audit
assignments uh of 30 uh during the uh
during the whole year and as at the end
of June we'd we'd done work around 11 of
those so we're well on track
for the overall Target as of today which
were nearly at the halfway stage
um we're up to 18 so we're well on track
at the moment with that
um
there is a listing of all the audits in
terms of where they're up to or
plan how they're planned in in appendix
two of the report
um
in terms of plan I say planned work but
we're nearly at the end of the period
now in terms of July to September
um we've been issuing the final reports
that that were a draft stage we've been
doing some more Grant certification work
um and we're also strategic risk
register work and we'll be starting
process of putting together a report
which the committee will get to at the
next meeting and there's a new exercise
linking in with David Wright's item
earlier around the national fraud
initiative where we'll be working with
David's team and others
um to help submit data to the cabinet
office for so for future data matching
which the likes a day David's team will
be uh undertaking during the year
um and then just to draw your attention
to the appendices there uh starting on
page 85 just shows an analysis of uh
planned planned against actual time
during the period but appendix 2 shows
you the list of assignments and uh
progress progress to date so I can I'll
give another update on July to September
uh that's our next meeting
thanks Mark any comments questions
councilor Winton
[Music]
I just wanted to say really that um
there's so much in this report
um which is a good story a great story
and at the risk of uh of causing Mark to
blush I think his him and his team are
unsung heroes of of this Council in in a
number of respects
um the work that they do to contribute
to
um high standards and improving
standards across the whole of the
council in effect and and further into
schools
um I think it's it uh it's it's
incredible it's it's it's it's a great
story and
um it I think it's as a as a counselor
I draw an awful lot from it an awful lot
of
um uh encouragement
um about the work that he's done in the
council and the the monitoring and the
and the and the policing uh of of
Standards um so
um really just a lot of words to say uh
well done marked to to you and your team
thank you very much
yeah when you think people outside of
think local authorities are run
haphazardly obviously it's not the case
and you know Mark and his team and other
officers keep a tight Reign on the
finances anybody else I'm sorry I've
forgotten with anybody else said
anything no
okay thanks for that we'll go on to item
uh 10 the um the work program I think
yeah
[Music]
can we note that
okay thanks very much
item 11 urgent business I'm not being
informed of any so we're not going to
discuss that look and then item 12
exclusion well maybe nothing
confidential to discuss so uh we can
pass over that so thanks very much
that's the end of the meeting
and we can close the uh YouTube channel
down thank you